amazing i'm here with a legendary reds
catboy yeah hey i'm red cat boy who is
um
becoming quite famous in london for his
activism
can you have a give a yeah bend down
show me your
maga hat yeah there you go so what
happened to your other day in
sainsbury's
you refused service um basically in
sainsburys i went there
um i i was refused service they saw my
hat
you know how these people at like
they're trying to act all cool so
they're like
whoa whoa whoa and then they said they
wouldn't serve me there's two of them
um eventually after like five ten
minutes i got served by the manager who
came out from the back to serve me
but that should not i should not be
refused service by
two people and then what made it worse
is
the next day i phoned head office to
complain about this because i know that
if
i done it to let's say a muslim or to
someone with saying a
sign saying trump grabs [__] i would be
fired straight away
but what happened is when i phoned them
they then phoned the shop to see what
happened and the shop told them the
reason why they wouldn't serve me
is because i was shying racist abuse at
the staff
which is totally forced i did not say
anything to the staff
and what's your own national heritage um
i was actually born in russia but i grew
up here
right so that's bizarre that anyone
would accuse you of racism
europe i was evicted um from speaker's
corner just yesterday
you were you were two weren't you with
your usa flag
yes several royal parks buckingham
palace
and because corners are flying the
british flag and
trump flag well yesterday in speaker's
corner there was a muslim man saying
kill gays and the gays should die and i
said to police officer that's hate
speech he said to me no it's not this is
true this is corner
it's free speech i said no it's not it's
hate speech it depends which side you're
on like
and if you say that and you're muslim
it's fun
but so what's the worst thing i know
that you were your refused
service have you been physically beaten
have you been assigned
um i was um
i was attacked um by beer and things
like that
i've always had people get verbally
violent but
um actually um i got lost my job because
someone reported me if i had a trump
protest saying i was
um shouting racist stuff at trump
protests
but i got a new job pretty easily took
me an hour to get a new job
easy i don't really care no skin off me
i got a new better job anyway but the
point is
that they should not have the power and
these liberals are mean
and they are not tolerant at all
i will never go up to them and try to
get them fired i know but like
the way they did it they for example
when like one of these people
saw me at trump like so went to my
like saw me at my shop then saw me
at a rally or something like that
and obviously called up pret like
the place i used to work and complained
to them
which is totally like unfair so my last
question is
first of all um really really i applaud
your courage
um where do you get it from where do you
find the courage to carry on and do all
this
no you just do it like it's just like i
said the main thing is just
you can allow stuff to get to you like
for example a lot of people would care
if they got fired from their job
i just brush it off i got myself a new
job in less than an hour
easy easy peasy you just move on you